hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 21 of my 1H hour flipping
challenge today we're going to be taking
on a pretty broad category um I just
pretty much want to flip anything but
it's still a category technically today
we're going to be flipping known buying
limits I going to get these right from
the wiki and GE tracker so I mean it's a
load of items it could be almost any
item that's worth doing uh but it's
still a category we're going to start
with 40 mil and we'll see how it goes
all right let's get started
okay guys we have 40 mil in our
inventory and we are going to be
flipping the known buying limits of any
item it's a broad category but today we
don't really feel like being restricted
too much so 40 mil let's go all right so
we have the uh list open here and we're
going to sort uh we already actually
have sorted by um the lowest item first
the lowest item limit uh because we want
to get those in there first uh so items
like the magic Fang only has a five
quantity limit on there uh we definitely
want to do first uh cuz it'll take a
while to actually buy and sell those but
they can be pretty
profitable uh let's put in for 2 four
35 do two those to begin with all right
and for the Ser time Visage uh we're
going to put an offer
in oh I don't know let's see what the
averages are looking
like
2473 that seems reasonable
74k and do two of those 414 yeah so
mahogany logs does tend to have good
margins on them put them in for
415 and it let's do
5K
10K 253
into
250 that's not
bad 10K blood
okay we bought our first magic Fang for
2435 uh we're going to pop that in there
for let overdo a bit 2480 see how that
goes 4125 into 412 that's not too bad
actually 4126 for an item that does
trade quite
frequently um do four of those 4126 now
what about the dragon Arrow oh we
actually sold our magic Fang that is a
45k profit pretty decent and we bought a
Berserker ring as well uh we're looking
to sell those again for 4155 oh and
there we go we bought the other magic
Fang 2480 is what we want to sell it for
248k and that is an insane margin so
we'll go ahead and put another offer in
for magic
fangs two yeah looks good to me well I
have made a lot of money off this item
once but it does tend to have a pretty
big margin yeah look at that um not
really sure how many of these I could
expect to
get I'll just go with 3K for now and
there we go we got our offer slots
pretty much filled up uh we actually
just got a Ser
Visage um but our offer slots are pretty
much full we've used all 40 mil all we
can really do is wait and start reacting
oh my God I keep we keep buying
Berserker rings every single second
4155 keep needing to reput that in there
hopefully that is the right price
okay we did sell the magic Fang for 2480
that is another 45k in profit not bad at
all uh pretty happy with that
maybe yeah sure we'll leave it at that
for now and see how that goes ah there
we go we got two of the Berserker Rings
sold I think we're getting 20K on each
one uh I to get these feeling these
Dragon arrows really not going to happen
they're going to come through way too
slowly uh so we'll go ahead and just
sell those off
and there we go we sold off all the
Berserker Rings really not too bad uh
we'll definitely put another offer in
for those
[Music]
sure [__] me oh well um we got the magic
Fang coming in for
2435 and uh pop that in for 2480 with
the other one I mean like even on this
little tiny bit of logs 475 and at
bottom for 435 like that's 40K in profit
right there um so really pretty decent
okay we're actually able to buy a
Berserker ring for 4110 kind of just low
ball it cuz I thought the price went
have dipped a bit and uh we also did
manage to sell two of our Berserker
Rings uh but the last one stopped
selling we'll pop these two in here for
41 42k 41 42k looks decent one is going
to be a marginal loss and the other one
is going to be a 32k profit Snap Dragon
sees do work quite well okay we actually
got some magic fangs coming through too
but let's put this offer in
first uh yep that's pretty decent for
the seeds 22 100 900k in profit will be
180k in profit sorry if we actually sell
all the seeds going to be a dick
here and 199 seeds boom four M pop that
in there okay uh so magic Fang did sell
for 2480 that is another 45k in profit
and we have a new Fang as well um but I
think that might be pretty close to the
limit so we're going to just pop those
in there they'll sell eventually and we
will have gotten our money from this
item okay wow we have a lot of stuff
sold magic Fang sold perfect Ser time
Visage we sold for
2500 another 25k profit there got
another two Ser visages pop in for
2500 2500k
[Music]
and oh sorry we have another magic Fang
we're going to put in for what are we
sell them for again 2480 such a good
margin and on top of that I think we
actually did sell another Berserker ring
not bad there 8 one 0
20 and let's do 10 whips okay we
actually sold off the last Berserker
ring pretty decent um don't really
remember what the margin was looking
like on that one okay the death Rune has
a very large margin of them so we'll
definitely do the death Rune that is
like a eight GP margin on death runes
that's 80k potentially in profit
31200 and 3501 that's still a pretty
decent margin for seeds considering the
limit is actually
200 30
502 and
199 and that's completed we got full
offer slots again and we just kind of
have to wait so band's godsword is the
next candidate
here um we'll go ahead and check the
margin I think and that will start with
five
hopefully Okay so we've solded the super
time Visage uh that was another 30k or
something profit um but we also did get
a Bandos godsword uh which again we're
plopping in here for 31 17 pretty good
margin on that hopefully we can actually
sell it for that price okay we sold off
the M mahogany logs uh pretty good
actually I kind of want to continue
buying those okay and we have sold one
of the Bandos godswords that is a nice
amount of money okay so we're definitely
going to continue on with these Bandos
godswords we've sold two of them now and
we bought another one okay so that's not
anything so we'll leave that for now uh
but we did sell off all the Bandos God
swords for 3108 pretty decent margin
there okay so we've bought another
Bandos godsword for 379 so we're going
to put an offer in for three more uh
we're just going to do three this time
though 379 three we're buying them good
to go the snap dragon seeds have all
bought which was pretty decently
quick uh just check the margin one more
time
though I can't do thatth is there any
way to know what we're buying them for
31199 I don't know do that we'll see how
that goes Sol scales hopefully just has
two DP at least one 12 six
one two three three GP actually that's
pretty good should have done that a
while
ago and 30k it's probably not going to
happen but we will give it a try that's
a really good margin on Raw
monkfish um yeah
dang for what the item is and I believe
this should buy pretty quickly you think
so anyway let's look at Raw monk fish
quickly yeah I mean there 1.5 million
traded a day that just like shouldn't
take very long okay and all the RAR
seeds have sold pretty decent on the
seeds and uh we actually bought all the
Zer skills already that was a pretty
quick buy I mean they normally are but
sometimes they can take a little
longer 26 so that be a nice uh 30k in
profit there so obviously these Bandos
godswords have changed prices
again and uh we're probably just going
to focus on selling them now plop them
down a little bit okay is uh it's been a
while
398 wow all the Jesus they're all sold
right away that was easy guess we got
the right price there about magic
logs then we bought for
1,85 and we sold for
1,76 now that is pretty
decent um we'll just put that in sure
why not all right in the last 10 15
minutes we'll try doing some death runes
it's only a 2 GP margin but who knows
maybe this time we actually buy some
okay so we have 12 minutes left we have
a bit of a mess of a grind exchange
right now boom three sell offers kind of
going through haven't made any sales in
a while three buy offers kind of the
same
thing I'm not sure I'm kind of thinking
of just calling it now let's just cut
the buy off off oh what just
happened okay maybe I should wait a
little longer actually no we're going to
pull the death runes out now pop him for
263 that's another little bit of profit
there raw monkfish got 1,000 so not too
bad okay um so the monkfish have sold
20K there not too bad uh the magic logs
are selling uh death runes are selling
Snap Dragon seeds aren't so we're going
to lower them down a little bit 31 is
we'll plop them in now for um but while
I was talking the magic logs also did
complete and we're still actually buying
them um well no we're not we were
planning on it doesn't look like any are
coming through 8 minutes left and we'll
probably cut this off in probably 3
minutes okay we only got 6 minutes left
so we're going to pull out the magic
logs done on those uh Zar
scales might drop down to one
25 uh question mark Cuz they have not
sold for like 20 minutes it's been a
while so we'll put them down there Snap
Dragon seeds did miraculously all sell
at once which is pretty nice and death
runes are selling hopefully we can sell
this magic Fang in time um but pretty
confident in the
rest okay guys we are down to 30 seconds
left uh we did manag to sell these
dollar scales for a one GP profit on the
rest of them not awful I guess two GP in
the death runes will give us 16k and we
did not manage to sell the magic Fang we
must have been undercut or something uh
cuz we bought like four we bought five
of them in the first like half an hour
this one we've been waiting to sell
forever uh but that's okay we'll pull it
out and dump it we'll see what we end up
with two seconds left one get rid of
that beat before it happens there we go
time's up pull that
out and uh we'll just dump
it for 23
that kind of sucks
2300 how much do we lose on
that uh I think we bought it for
[Music]
20 that's a good loss on that actually
oh well it's kind of the way it goes so
we'll go see how long how much money we
made from 1 hour of FL
fing the known buying limits uh from the
RuneScape
Wiki started with 40 mil and we are
going to end with
40.7 mil so not too bad I kind of
thought I could do better uh My overall
thoughts was it was a little too
overwhelming having like all those items
to look through uh having like there's
probably 200 items on that list there
not all of them are good but quite a few
of them are decent but but I mean 700k
still not too bad probably would have
been closer to 8 or
900k had we not lost that on the end
there but uh yeah hope you guys enjoyed
and I will see you guys in the next
episode
[Music]